to me
if you
make
any more bad decisions between now and
midterms everybody knows it's not going
to be pretty
but tom if let's just say they flip 70
seeds 80 seeds if it's a blood bath of
all time you got to figure out a way to
not make it the blood bath of all time
that's embarrassing it's so bad that the
story comes out folks just yesterday
on uh what's taking place where's that
story yet in regards to people retiring
where's that story
okay there's a page five go on page five
okay so this story is absolutely mind
boggling on what the story is surge in
house democratic 2022 retirement
announces as 2021
comes to a close a trio of democrats and
a house representative representative
stephanie murphy of florida lucille roy
uh royal roy
ballard of california albio cedars of
jersey last week said that they'll
retire at the end of the year
rather than run again in 2022 midterms
for another term in congress the latest
news brought 23 to the number of house
democrats who are retiring or bidding
for another office rather than run for
reelection in 2022
with when their party tries to defend
its razor thin majority in the house the
gop needs to net gain of just five seats
in the 435
member chamber next year to regain house
majority of laws to democrats in 2018
midterms republicans have history on the
side on the average party that wins the
white house in a presidential election
loses more than 25 seats in the ensuing
midterm election how ugly you think it's
going to get to the point where guys are
retiring well i think there's three
things going on here thing number one is
they know what you're about to say about
or what i think you're about to say is
correct
right now look history's not on your
side midterm is usually tough for the
party in the white house okay we have to
contain our losses point number one but
point number two is we have so much
going on social there's not this isn't
just a a controversy
you know like with monica lewinsky or
something this is a nationwide
multi-year pandemic that's hitting the
economy and now the wave is pushing back
against the administration so the
administration has got that going on and
then the third thing that's going on is
this is also historical right now you've
got a lot more republican governors and
what is happening in the states is all
the redistricting which is why we've got
these districts that look so freaking
weird the way they're set and so you
have redistricting some might call that
gerrymandering yeah it is for
republicans or democrats it's
gerrymandering and so right now you've
got a lot of folks that are feeling like
their
alternate party uh governor is
gerrymandering them out of a seat that
even if we didn't have all the covid and
all the national pandemic and everything
that goes with it right now there's a
whole bunch of people that are being
gerrymandered right out of the seat so
and this is a trick that both sides use
but there happens to be more republican
governors right now and so i think they
got to contain they have to contain
contain and when these folks can
announce retirement early they can at
least get maybe something of a candidate
up that's what i think's going on yeah
well they're also you know when when red
landing happens man
the far left in the party is where all
the money is that's where everything's
coming from and they're primarying their
own people so there's a people people
don't realize there's a civil war within
the democratic party right now
and the progressives have won the
progressives have hijacked nancy pelosi
because that's where the money is and
people like aoc we talk about a lot
because she's a fire brand and all she's
she's not a very powerful person in in
in terms of what she can actually
accomplish as a legislate as a
legislator but she's an incredibly
powerful person with her voice her
ability to raise funds her turn my aoc
yeah i'm sorry are you telling me aoc
yeah so what they do what the
quote-unquote squad does what justice
democrats do it's justice democrats if
you guys want to look it up on twitter
if you want to know what nancy pelosi is
going to say tomorrow follow justice
democrats today
they're think tank and they're they're
probably the most powerful lobby in the
world right now so psychotracker body is
the most powerful man in america that
nobody knows who his name is it's like a
chatty cathy doll you pull the string on
those democrats and nancy please very
dangerous human being so what happens is
that they don't run in purple districts
they don't put progressives up in purple
districts they don't go after
republicans they go after democrats they
hollow out their own base they go after
heavy blue areas and then they run to
the left of that and that's what you're
seeing well you know the new new york
governor probably why cuomo was ousted
was because he was for all intents and
purposes of moderate in today's world
and they wanted far left push hard left
push wanted to get on board i got rid of
them so when you're looking at what's
happening right now you're going to see
the left double down and triple down
because they're going to lose in the
midterms and you're going to have i
guarantee you mark this right now an
hour and a half into this podcast aoc is
going to grandstand and say
they didn't ask us to help they didn't
ask us to fundraise they didn't ask us
to come in and she's going to blame the
bloodbath on the fact that they tried to
appeal to the moderate voter instead of
rally the left base
she wants to win on the fringe she's not
here for america she's here for the
revolution
and that's what's happening right now
within that side that's where the
money's going yeah but okay so let's
just say that's the case fine you want a
different angle the angle i'm going
right now is
are they going to be even more extreme
between now and midterm so you said i
don't think they're going to make uh
woody color domestic travel mandatory to
be
shown your vaccination card here's what
i will tell you i think it's a bad move
if they do i think it's going to hurt
them even more at midterms if they do i
think the smarter was not to do it i
agree i agree with that but by the way
here's the part if they're strategic
don't do it if they do it they're going
to piss off a lot of regular people that
their job relations
like i'm not even double vaccinated you
know i would be like dude no yeah
exactly so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]